the US dollar has been on a tear this
year and it's set to get stronger so
much so that the rest of the world may
need to intervene to limit the damage to
their own currencies and economies we
pulled a group of professional investors
and 70 of them see the Bloomberg US
dollar Index rising over the next month
30 see it going down the Bloomberg U.S
dollar Index tracks the dollar against
the basket of other currencies and is up
almost 14 in 2022 almost half of the
survey respondents expect several
governments to band together to try to
stop the Dollar's rally because while
the strong dollar is great news for
Americans visiting the UK Europe Japan
Canada the list goes on it's terrible
for countries that need to import food
or fuel which is often priced in dollars
it's also a double whammy for us-based
companies that do business overseas
here's how their stuff becomes more
expensive in those markets and therefore
less attractive and the value of those
overseas sales are worth less when
converted back to dollars so watch for
Corporate America to blame the dollar
when companies give updates on why their
sales and profit growth are slowing and
how they plan to manage some par results
Often by cutting costs
[Music]